Kenyan troops in kibumba in North kivu
Province they are holding forth in areas
from where the armed group M23 has
withdrawn Regional East African forces
from Kenya
Uganda South Sudan and Burundi are here
to enforce an agreement aimed at
bringing peace to the region
hundreds of people have been killed and
up to 1 million forced out of their
homes since the conflict started over a
year ago
some congoles living in kibumba say they
are afraid to go back home despite m-23
Fighters pulling out
the group has seeded strategic towns and
roads but fighting is still going on in
some parts
Rwanda has been accused by the UN the EU
and others of supporting the rebels
Kigali denies this
according to an agreement signed by
Regional leaders M23 is to move to
Sabino in virunga mountains near the
Rwanda Buddha but the rebels have not
gone there yet the destination that they
are going it is in line the what is
agreed upon but whether they are getting
there until I get to that position to go
and validate
then I can be able to tell you
authoritatively that for sure they have
reported there
the regional forces were deployed a few
months ago they say they are here to
facilitate a political process between
Kinshasa and M23 but some analysts say
the negotiations are moving too slowly
and while everyone talks about a
political track and a military truck
there is no clear understanding on what
should come first and how that should
evolve M23 leaders say they want direct
talks with the government Kinshasa
insists it cannot negotiate until all
areas controlled by the rebel Fighters
are vacated
that deadlock is unbroken and Congolese
who've been forced out are now living
rough and comps for the displaced and
suffering Catherine soy Al Jazeera